that's the thing that the government has
never really talked about about Silk
Road was whether you like it or not with
you either or not it wasn't political
engine it's motive was coming out so
first of all I thought it was a great
home thank you
one of the best documentaries I've ever
seen I think and you tell a very
complicated story it's complicated in a
number of ways politically and otherwise
the technology explaining a lot of that
and you do it very clearly and
excessively and I was fairly blown away
oh thank you oh I got here about 20
minutes ago it's so depressing walking
in at the end of this movie hey we do so
how I mean first of all so how did you
how did you that for an uplift how did
you how did you get to this project
I mean clearly takes a lot of passion
Tory go through all that work oh I'll
try to keep this short I guess the short
version is is I I got interested in the
Internet in the 80s and this is the
short version I promise
saddle up and I was interested in the
BBS news group community and and what I
found fascinating at that time was was
not so much computers and technology but
that there were these rapidly growing
online communities that were really
because of the freedom and anonymity of
the Internet and the newness of it
there was a sort of democratizing
component where people really felt free
to talk about anything and so there was
some very radical discourse going on at
that time on the Internet
you don't need to be unlike one of the
hackers there were a lot of hacker
groups that were harder to get into
that's
when I met Sean Fanning and Sean Parker
later when I made the Napster movie
that's where those guys were this is
just straight-up regular communities any
idiot like myself could get into these
anyway they were very similar to what
grew to become the darknet communities
and I've followed them through the years
and I've just been very interested in
this in the sort of more sociological
aspect of the growth of online community
so I wanted to tell stories in that
space I made the Napster movie and then
when I watched the Silk Road happen in
2012 when I learned about it and then
when Ross was arrested in 13 it was
really clear that to me that Silk Road
was the next big seismic shift in online
communities Napster was the first global
Internet community that's really why it
has significance 100 million people
online at once that never happened
before Silk Road was the first time you
had a full scaling efficient anonymous
online community that was a waters it's
a watershed moment and it's going to
showing a lot of change so that's why I
wanted to tell that story in a nutshell
and toward the end of the film
Andy Bloomberg who's the wired reporter
but I think he's also a producer on the
film's that right yeah he was like a
consulting producer he wrote a really
great book called the this Machine Kills
secrets that I'd read which is sort of
touted as a WikiLeaks book it isn't
really it's really a fantastic book
about the evolution of cryptography in
the cypherpunks
so I knew I wanted him involved really
early on we got him involved he says a
an interesting thing that also sort of
confused me because he didn't quite to
spell it out he said he's conflicted
about the meaning of Silk Road and Ross
Ulbricht and he didn't quite explain his
conflict I mean I took him to be
basically a partisan throughout the film
of Ulbricht and Silk Road in that
general project then he says if they're
in that he was actually conflicted about
it I'm wondering I mean do you know what
he meant by that and then I'm also
wondering if you're conflicted about
their meaning I think that what what
Andy is saying and you know there's a
lot that flies by in this movie it's
it's it's evident in this in by the
bluntness with which he says he agrees
with the gun
position on the case it's very
interesting given the journey that he's
been on that he comes to that conclusion
he believes the government has proven
that Ross is guilty and so to him
Ross's DPR rosted all these things and
yet he was also this idealistic this is
Andy's you know opinion that he's lived
with this guy via DPR for so many year
for for years and very very in a very
detailed micro fashion and yet to have
to reconcile the possibility that he had
become potentially corrupted that there
were all these other in affairs things
that had gone on the breadth and scope
of what had gone down on the Silk Road
left him in a really conflicted place
psychologically and and I which I find
fascinating because you know for me as a
filmmaker I was not actually conflicted
because for me as an observer or having
watched this whole thing happen I didn't
ever really get impacted by things that
hadn't been proven in court and I know a
lot about hackers and so I wasn't I
didn't totally swallow everything had
been presented and because Ross was
never formally charged with attempted
murder and that was never proven in
court
I never occurred to me to assume that
that emotionally to get invested in the
idea that he had done those things
because I needed to see them proven and
I know and we never did get to see them
proven and so from an ethical standpoint
it never even occurred to me to try to
put forward a position that Ross was
guilty of something that he had never
had the opportunity to defend himself
against in court
I just never crossed my mind so I find
Andy interesting and I love a need in
death but it's not actually position I
agree with and then on the other side
you have the parents who are vehement
that Ross is 100% innocent and truth is
probably somewhere between the two and
in the middle of that in the ether point
is we don't know we don't absolutely
concrete
the trial was abbreviated I was there it
was very short there was very little
that got communicated and there's a lot
that I happen to know that we don't know
it has many public I mean for those of
us who more or less thing is a hero of
some sort I mean we need him to be
guilty right yeah he's not a hero unless
he actually is guilty of the major
charge of running Silk Road right that
seems to be fairly clear it seems like
most people involved in the case agree
with that well he I mean in a minute
even here in a minute Ross said he he
Ross has admitted to creating Silk Road
Ross's position is I created Silk Road I
am not prepared robbers I created it I
got it up and running it was a team
effort a community effort and I bailed
out and I had a hand in it and that's
his position we don't we don't I don't
know any more than that other than that
I do know from my inside perspective
that there were several people that were
running the Silk Road on the Jim Pirate
Roberts account I know three of them but
that doesn't mean necessarily and you
know there could be a reality in which
he ran it and gave the administrative
you know password over to somebody
because he couldn't be online 24 hours a
day seven days so I thought when I guess
I'm wrong I thought that what Greenberg
was referring to in terms of his own
conflict was over just the freedom that
Silk Road offered right that there will
be wonderful things wonderful benefits
from it but also potentially quite dark
downsides do know Andy likes all this I
mean you know Andy's very Pro the
freedoms that the that the the internet
offers and he's very a nut but words
about just knowing I mean he's you know
he sort of moans as I do the ways in
which the Internet has got hobbled over
the years and like I said like to me to
be on the PBS news group era was very
romantic and the darknet is also very
romantic and it's been demonized and
there were bad things that happen there
just like there are bad things that
happen anywhere human beings congregate
but this notion of a privacy and
anonymity ridden you know or driven
community that is mostly journalists and
you know human rights organizations
you know government agents that need to
be able to protect themselves and a lot
of people speaking freely and wanting
change is a romantic ideal it's a
dangerous one and it's one that a lot of
people want to see snuffed out all right
so I'm a u.s. historian and I couldn't
help but be reminded of prohibition
right and the uses of technology to
basically subvert laws yeah that we now
all think should have been subverted
right at the card
yeah right so the the high speed car
that was used by bootleggers in the
south and those speed boats that were
used to bring booze through the
Caribbean and you know I so I'm thinking
there's definitely a parallel there or
it's analogous in some ways and then I'm
thinking but but these guys as far as we
know didn't kill anybody
right but they serve the same purpose or
are serving the same purpose I think
that what they will do to drugs is the
same thing that the Mafia did to alcohol
in the 20s which is basically subvert
these laws right yeah I mean the thing
that's happening is is you know the drug
war has given way to the Al Capone's of
today which are not Ross I mean these
gigantic cartels were you know you're
dealing with billions of dollars of drug
trade and mass murder on a massive scale
and political upheaval those are the Al
Capone's of prohibition yeah I was
thinking through this today I watched
the film earlier this morning and then I
was thinking through it and it's sort of
its I guess the difference is that he
didn't actually become a dealer himself
like the Mafia did right in the 20s he
essentially just created an alternate
world in which this trade could go on
unrestricted right yeah I think that the
categorical difference there's two two
significant issues one is the size is it
was a big community it's a tiny drug
market in the scheme of things from a
business standpoint and a law
enforcement standpoint there's it's a
puny puny drug market it's not it's a
respect in the water of the drug trade
that's not why the Silk Road was a
threat to law enforcement the the drive
in the media and from law enforcement to
to present the Silk Road
this horrific I mean there were never
hit men on the Silk Road
there's never actually no hit men on the
darknet if you see that in the in the
media at this point they actually know
they're full of [ __ ] they there's no
evidence of any hyperbole it's mostly
Charles like making fun of idiots who go
online look for people to kill people
but there's no evidence that anyone ever
either advertising for legitimately or
utilizing hitmen so there's no real
murder-happy there's a most of the drugs
that were sold oh Silk Road was pot
there wasn't a ton of any drug but what
I encountered in researching the movie
which was a surprise to me is that
everybody that I met with in the Silk
Road was political so the difference in
terms of what you're saying along way
around the answer question is Ross is
political you know if you dig into you
know he's a very staunch libertarian and
everybody else that I interviewed
including the guy in red who was one of
the largest dealers on Silk Road and
helped scale the user interface and he's
still at large so it's an interesting
person but he's super political
everybody there they were there to use
technology to dismantle the drug war and
to create deregulated communities so
that's the thing that the government has
never really wanted talked about about
Silk Road was whether you like it or not
whether you agree with it or not it was
a political engine it's motive was
purely political one of the charges
against libertarianism and against I
suppose Internet users like this is that
they are profoundly sort of anti so if
not just individual lists but they're
antisocial right and in a way this film
is an extended critique of that right
yeah these people were actually
primarily sort of end with that thing
with Ross wishing for more connection
with human beings you know it's sort of
the it's this that the prime seems in
some way the primary motivation for him
was community to establish an
alternative community but today with
people and if they're in a virtual way
yeah I mean the the the myth of the
hoodie wearing sociopath illogical
hacker that we continually see in the
media
I mean is laughable and and I remember
when I met Shawn Fanning in 2000 when
Napster was was crumbling and you know
these guys like you know these were the
most social guys you'd ever met in your
life I mean the myth about about
creating large technologies is that one
person doesn't you know it's a guy in a
hoodie with a laptop like mr. Roboto or
the social networks portrayal Zuckerberg
you know as opposed to how these systems
are actually created which is by
community we can't mount a large-scale
technology like Silk Road like Napster
like Amazon without a massive community
and it's never one guy with a laptop but
usually you know like Zuckerberg is
super social and not at all like he was
portrayed and has had the same
girlfriend since you as fairly yeah I
mean you know they're not sociopaths
they're kind of geek they're smart but
they're kind of geeky guys they have a
lot of friends it requires a lot of
friends requires this huge network in
order to build these same we saw Silk
Road was a community run operation those
that did not surprise me as I scratch
the surface I found this core community
of people that have put that thing
together but that's Anathem of the way
we want to present these narratives you
know the idea that that these are our
community sort of oriented people is
anathema to the sort of prevailing
narrative one fact that is not in the
film which Kurt Loder told me about via
Twitter today and I think he told you
too was that I guess the judge in the
case was recommended for nomination to
the bench by Charles Schumer yeah I had
to keep my mouth shut about that all
year long so tough yeah I mean the
network is really I mean you know in a
certain level it's not surprising
politics is politics and you know a lot
of people when Ross got arrested and he
got extradited from San Francisco to New
York they were like when they saw that
he's being tried in Southern District of
New York they were like he's totally
[ __ ] and this was like a year and a
half ago it's a very tight-knit
community you know and Schumer and the
DEA in the process
either in the judge I mean they're
tight-knit community and they're the
Southern District of New York tries a
lot of financial regulation cases
there's a lot of people that believe
this case is really a bitcoin case and
it's really more about the threat to
Wall Street markets than it is to
anything else in terms of the level of
commitment that they had and shutting
this thing down and making an example
out of Ross I mean you know there's been
a lot of articles written about that you
can look him up but it's yeah it's a
very tight-knit community and Schumer
made it very clear that he wanted you
know this to be dealt with in an extreme
manner I notice the I forget his name
but I think the other Congress person
who led the fight against Silk Road is
also a Democrat man mentioned yeah yeah
it was the two of them right so it's
sort of a well you're also dealing with
those old school issues old school drug
war issues you know there's so many
issues at play it's really harrowing to
watch a case like this happen sitting in
the courtroom you realize that once the
button gets switched and the Machine
just kind of cranks into gear it just
it's just unstoppable and you know there
was a kind of lumbering almost
thoughtlessness to it to the way Ross
was just kind of trampled into the dust
and it was really harrowing to watch and
and the machines set up it's it's setup
to dismantle drug war issues it's set up
to dismantle cyber Ross had the
misfortunate Lee getting stuck in the
crosshairs of those two over prosecuted
areas in our judicial system which is
cyber and the drug war he's smack in the
middle of both which never go well for
him
what's what's the reaction to the film
Ben well it's been you know varied we'd
had a overall a really really great and
positive reaction which has been
wonderful I knew the film would be
contentious we didn't set out to make it
provocative but we did set out to tell
the story the way we side and we've been
you know I've been in all over the world
with a movie been invited festivals all
over the world I'm really happy the
reviews that we got even people that
don't like it it seems to have hit a
nerve with them and
I don't really you know I don't mean
some flippant but I don't care so much
if someone likes a dock like this or not
as much as if they you know if their
brains get kind of kicked into gear by
it on some level you know They ve
disagree with the way we're presenting
it that's okay so it has it has had a
ripple effect which I'm happy about I
got a letter from Ross from prison last
week you know where he said he's really
you know again with you like piranha and
I have to caveat I don't really know
Ross you know Ross has been unattainable
and inaccessible to me because of the
severity of the crime but he wrote me
this very astute letter the other day
where he just said you know I'm not sure
if this is gonna have any impact on my
appeal like regardless of me I'm getting
all these letters in prison by people
who didn't know anything about this
world and about the drug war about you
know the way cybers me over prosecuted
and the way the darkness being demonized
and he was just really happy to see that
that you know I think it was satisfying
to him to see that dialogue happening a
little bit and I was happy to see that
again you know I it's we didn't set out
to try to defend him and I don't really
know enough to do that one where the
other I do hope he gets an appeal I do
hope that we get to see a substantive
case trial anyway which we haven't seen
yet great well I'd love to take some
questions or we like to say take some
questions from the audience
no there's no way you can't legally
interview them and I'm from the fact no
the reason I didn't pursue any of this
after the fact was twofold one was
creative I actually wanted the movie to
end with the sentencing in terms of just
being information I mean this story is
just what's happening with those few
federal agents are so much more to this
story it's just beginning right but it's
a movie I wanted it to have a beginning
a middle and an end I wanted that to be
the end so I didn't want to just keep
interviewing people secondarily to your
point specifically if you had been in
the courtroom like I wasn't you have
seen the jury you would not not be that
interested in interviewing them you know
they were either asleep or you know
reading stuff or looking really confused
but it was you know they do know what
the hell is a kid no idea what the hell
was going on I mean they really didn't
understood yeah sure yeah yeah I think
that that you know I was at the
sentencing and the second thing was
interesting because you know a lot of
people don't like Ross there's a thing
about Ross he's like a litmus test he's
either a libertarian hero or crypto
anarchist revolutionary or an evil drug
mongering murderous Doug he's all these
different things to all these people so
the sentencing which had an overflow
room there were so many people there was
filled with people with varied ideas
about Ross they were not like it was not
a cheering section by any stretch but
everybody was blown away by the sentence
everybody people were like there were
all these sort of Judiciary students all
these legal students that were in them
they were just freaking out when the
sentence was read and what was really
chilling about the sentence and I said
that I think I said this occurred after
that after the sentencing was like I
actually believe it I never really fell
that hard on one side at the other I
just wanted to know what happened you
know it was it possible that Ross did
all those things including trying to
have people killed I don't know it's
possible
no one's proven it they didn't even
charge him with it in the end but it's
possible but the sentencing I had a hard
and fast opinion about it was
was wrong and it's excessive and it
doesn't fit the charges so I think it's
helped him towards an appeal but you
know forest was really clear you know it
was a very long sentence it went on for
hours we thought we'd be out of there in
half an hour but she gave an almost
hour-long speech about the merits of the
drug war why it needed to be upheld and
why Ross needed to be made an example of
and how he disturbed the social fabric
of our society and how people who do use
technology in this way are disrupting
the social fabric of our study and we
must use Ross as an example so she just
bluntly said that she was making an
example out of them which was a you know
a very fairly chilling thing to watch
when the person was that young and you
know they're gonna be in a max it's not
that many Mac security prisons in
America so it's going to a fairly grim
place for what 60 years 50 years you
know progressives led the movement for
prohibition - yeah [ __ ] see that that's
right
because the the there was an argument
early on this is a question of
transferred intent is the is the is the
issue of if you are if you actually
FedEx was charged or was attempted to be
charged with this last year to where
they were I think it was California am i
right about that that that was claiming
that FedEx should be held responsible
for the drugs that were being moved and
other contraband that's being moved
through FedEx even though Fedak is not
aware of them and or and if they were
which is what the court was was
suggesting is that they actually were
aware of them that they were not as
possible so there's been questions
around where the Ross could be held
responsible for the negative or criminal
aspects of his site the judge argued
early on that transferred intent was not
applicable because the Silk Road was
clearly and even within its manifesto
created with a specific intent to
traffic contraband that's that's
debatable
i I think honestly actually had this
debate with someone to Q&A recently I
got very angry with me because I
wouldn't fall hard on the side of Ross
falling into the transported attempt to
be because the Silk Road you can't have
your cake it easy to you can't create a
revolutionary technology I didn't say
hey yeah you can do whatever you want
with it it was created as a
revolutionary technology so it's if you
do that you can't be surprised if
someone says I'm going to slack your
risk for creating a revolutionary
technology it's happening it happened an
app store and watch another scale but
honestly I think they're the two cases
are extremely similar
well quickly I found them many of them I
found them through a bunch of different
means I have encryption and I was
sending out sort of encrypted messages
through various places that I knew would
they be read and a lot of people got in
touch with me I did a Kickstarter a lot
of people got in touch with me through
PGP encryption because of the
Kickstarter people knew me because it
downloaded and they knew that I cared
about these issues they got touch with
me for that reason some people actually
even knew back from the BBS era that
were either political or moving drugs
online back then which was my first
interaction with both drugs online and
encrypted email is back in like 1990
some of those people were the same
people who were architecting the Silk
Road which is not surprising considering
how well a Tron wasn't just created by a
26 year old ok to no technical smells he
had a team of people that there were
team of people behind it that had
history online so that was that and and
sort of bleeds into your second question
because again like I said it and it was
a surprise to me I thought I was going
to find more to people who were dealing
drugs on the Silk Road because they like
drugs and I just I kept looking for
those people and I couldn't find him
everyone I met was political and you
know this guy was the guy in red who's a
one of the largest heroin dealers on
Silk Road but also one of the chief
technical architects of Silk Road was
you know political and I can't say more
than that but very political and had a
history and politics and cyber and all
of that and so they wanted to talk
because they did Silk Road if you were
on the Silk Road forms I don't know if
any of you were back when Silk Road was
running it was almost all political
discourse of Silk Road or it was talking
about drug safety and drugs from a
community standpoint and what's
interesting about this movie when it
does piss people off is is that it's an
unpalatable thing to discuss right like
what if you are a drug dealer and like
this guy you actually are heroin user
which he is and you're trying to help
your customers not overdose that's just
an extremely unpalatable thing to talk
about and people watching me like I like
that he's full of [ __ ] it's like I know
him really well he's you may not like
him but he's not full of [ __ ] like he
has done a lot of stuff to try to help
and there were other
there's on the Silk Road we're trying to
help people it's not to say it's a great
thing it's simply to say that someone
like Neil Franklin who's the the
executive director of Law Enforcement
Against Prohibition who speaks so
eloquently in the film you know these
people really believe that drugs
drug markets online or the future for
everyone's benefit
right the users and to dismantle the
drug war then you go to people like
Krista going from the ACLU or Sandy
Cohen from me at that who feel like the
dark net gets demonized and you know it
should be shouldn't be demonized and
there's a lot of goodness going on but
then you say okay well then it's at
least so crota's a good thing and most
of people I just mentioned will run for
the hills right because but that's
that's different that's like drug
dealers and it's crime and it's like all
this horrible [ __ ] I'm like you can't
have one without the other
you can you can't there has to be it's
got to start somewhere and it's usually
very radical criminal or sort of beyond
the law type people that aren't easy to
put in one box or no they're that start
these types of services that will evolve
into services that we all embrace and I
watched that happen with Napster with
all these people that thought Napster
was horrible is evil these guys were
evil and the Steve Jobs like pick
Napster up out of the ashes hired
everybody brought them into the iTunes
Store made a swing building deal with
the record industry and suddenly he's
okay you know and what he did is that's
cool and they're building a giant ass
building up north you know with all the
proceeds from that well you wouldn't
have had that without Shawn Fanning who
everyone uses a criminal it's impossible
but it's unpalatable to societies this
aside we don't like that we like to wait
out these these guys that rush through
the door that we think are unpalatable
so somebody a bit more palatable shows
up and picks up the actions of these
technology that makes it palpable and
that's part of why I wanted to tell the
story the way that I did which is you
may not like them but they are necessary
you know that's a really great question
and and I think we address it pretty
well in the movie because for me the
person who actually says the thing that
I think nails this thing is Cody
you know because Cody says look the
Libertarians can't handle the fact that
what if DPR and he doesn't go far as
Colin Rossi doesn't know where the Raza
TPR what a DPR did try to kill those
people right and nobody was killed so
there were no bodies there were no
deaths that were no murders but there
does seem to be somebody where there was
corrupt law enforcement agents or DPO or
Ross we don't know there's such a
tangled mess behind the veil of Silk
Road that was engaged in a murder
corruption plot Cody says okay let's
assume that was DPR well I still say
he's a hero in fact I say he's more of a
hero because he did that that's what I
would like to think I would do if I was
in this position because to me DPR is a
revolutionary he's not just some
libertarian who wants to create a
unregulated market place and screw the
government
no this guy is actually revolutionary he
wants to topple [ __ ] and he's willing to
go the distance to do it and I think
that that's an important notion to
contemplate again isn't to say that's
good or that's bad Cody's aware of the
provocative nature of that statement
Cody is largely about provocation but
it's not empty provocation he likes to
get people to think is how far are you
willing to go to have the society that
you want and how far does one have to go
in order to achieve that aim and it
isn't to say I mean most people get very
black-and-white they get very
dialectical like well are you saying
that's good well that's a terrible
things like no it's not about good or
bad it's just a fact of if you're going
to do something revolutionary you're
going to have to face some really
difficult choices what are you going to
do when you face those choices and what
does that mean about your legacy I've
also seen libertarians some libertarians
argue that it was an act of self-defense
or would have been an act of
self-defense that an informant working
for the state who's going to put you in
prison is that has actually initiated
aggression
right I mean yeah I thought it was a
fairly persuasive argument actually yeah
I'm not I don't have any information the
the I don't know anybody's name and the
media that you see of that guy is all
that exists now I've destroyed all of it
so there's no uncolored corrected media
of that guy it was just that he's baked
in silhouette and they have it because
it's out you know I've had there is no
other there's no there there so I
believe if they felt I had anything of
any value they would have come to me a
long time ago but then you have to deal
with this is the master story if to
remember they won stores why do they
talk to me guys going to jail for the
rest of his life what else do they want
to do you know they don't care the
reality of it is they don't care about
these guys they sell a penny-ante amount
of drugs they care about you know the
dude in Mexico that just walks through a
mile-long tunnel who's actually doing
stuff with the drug trade these guys are
like street corner guys as far as
they're concerned
yeah I mean there was a the if you go to
Reddit it's it's very deep with
everybody talking about what happened
and there's a lot of people there that
were heavily involved in Silk Road it's
not just trolling in fact that's how I
found a ton of people I was able to
verify them with PGP but there's a lot
there are people that went to jail that
got out of jail that are now freely
talking about what happened who record
architects at the Silk Road you know
there's a lot of discourse about all of
that there it's just you know a lot of
people there's nobody really giving
those ideas voice in the media so that
spark doesn't catch in terms of the
public public's awareness it's really
what you would consider underground
discourse but all of the sort of aspects
of the Silk Road if you go digging are
there I mean people are talking about it
every day
there's tons of Silk Road discourse
going on every day there has been since
you know before so crowed went down but
the narrative has been very fixed and
you know partly due to an agenda and
partly due to just ignorance people just
get really confused about the stuff they
don't know how to write about it I mean
I kept talking to people from New York
Times all these different people I you
know just call us we'll put a consultant
in your in your newsroom will explain
tor you know nobody called nobody gave a
[ __ ]
nobody told stories that made any sense
I mean it's not partisan to say a reason
was one of the only places that covered
this thing it was like three or four
people was nobody outside the courtroom
when he got sentenced nobody cared so
you know there there is tons of
discourse it just doesn't get any
airtime
thank you Alex thank you great yeah
you